some folks say What Goes Down In the
Heat of passion can haunt a body forever
that's life in Mississippi anyway
I have to ask some questions did your
daddy have any
enemies well well maybe I was the target
what do you mean I lost a lot of money
when the merger didn't go through people
lost thousands and thousands of dollars
[Music]
hello where will you be the minute you
wake up
dead
I got a call today sort of threatening
threatening phone calls this guy may not
be done
whenever there's a murder we ask who
stands to gain from it hello how is this
what can you tell me about the lane
she's been doing a lot of extra shifts
she'd like to gamble
when do I get my money I'm broke too why
do you think I'm doing all this
an insurance company wanted it's on line
one
we got a problem
if you had just been patient none of
this would have been necessary you're
being used
the land spans to get 500
000
to a perfect plan
[Music]
and getting rich
[Music]
right into their hands
[Music]
[Music]
I've been an Olympic and crying
we're trying to control it
[Music]